Rishi sunak arriving on a street he's
walked down many times before
but never as PM until now
no Fanfare or fuss or even family to
witness this moment
the new prime minister straight to it
his face telling its own story about
what lies ahead
right now
our country is facing a profound
economic crisis
the aftermath of covid still lingers
Putin's war in Ukraine has destabilized
energy markets and Supply chains the
world over
this a PM wanting to start over
acknowledging where his predecessor went
wrong she was not wrong to want to
improve growth in this country
it is a noble aim
and I admired her restlessness to create
change
but some mistakes were made
not born of ill will or bad intentions
quite the opposite in fact
that mistakes nonetheless
and I have been elected as leader of my
party
and your prime minister
in part
to fix them and promise him to try to
put it right but with a warning too none
of this is easy I will place economic
stability and confidence at the heart of
this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come the government I lead
will not leave the Next Generation
your children and grandchildren
with a debt to settle that we were too
weak to pay ourselves Frank about the
difficult economic choices but promising
to do government differently I will
unite our country
not with words
but with action
I will work day in and day out to
deliver for you
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
Trust
is earned and I will earn yours but not
yet trusting voters at The Ballot Box a
general election off the cards the
Mandate my party earned in 2019
is not the sole property of any one
individual
it is a mandate
that belongs to
and unites all of us
and the Heart of that mandate is our
Manifesto
I will deliver on its promise
after the politics came the personal
Rishi sunak leveling with the public I
fully appreciate how hard things are
and I understand too
that I have work to do to restore Trust
after all that has happened
all I can say
is that I am not daunted
I stand here before you
ready to lead our country into the
future
to put your needs above politics
together we can achieve incredible
things
and Phil tomorrow
and every day thereafter
with hope
thank you it's hope he'll need his mood
a manner Sirius and somber but signaling
too that he set on change how do you
unite the party
inside number 10 finally a smile for his
staff waiting in the wings to welcome
the new PM before getting down to work
earlier in the day Mr sunak arrived at
Buckingham Palace for his audience with
the King a new monarch not yet crowned
today appointing his first prime
minister and the country's third this
year a ritual of continuity against a
backdrop of change
late afternoon and his Majesty's
government forming fast suela bravaman
forced to quit as Home Secretary less
than a week ago for a security breach
controversially reappointed the
chancellor of just 11 days can you fix
the economy sir remaining in post and
big Johnson backers still in cabinet too
James cleverley remain in foreign
secretary Nadim zahawi moving to the
party chair
Dominic Robb and Oliver Dowden Friends
of the new prime minister staying close
a new cabinet a new start there were
some fresh faces but this a cabinet of
all the party even list trust's closest
Ally back inside number 10.
but the shortest ever-serving prime
minister was out after just seven weeks
with little apology about what she got
wrong as her husband and daughters
watched on in just a short period this
government has acted urgently and
decisively on the side of hard-working
families and businesses
short speech lasting just three minutes
but delivered with Defiance from my time
as prime minister I am more convinced
than ever that we need to be bold and
confront the challenges that we Face
quote in a Roman philosopher defending
hard decisions and tax cutting agenda we
simply cannot afford to be a low-growth
country where the government takes up an
increasing share of our national wealth
and where there are huge divides between
different parts of our country divides
she says she'll help bridge from the
back benches
our country continues to battle Through
Your Storm
but I believe in Britain
I believe in the British people
and I know that brighter days lie ahead
thank you and with that it was over Liz
truss's time in office terminated by
those who once put her in
Andover of power days like these are
meant to happen once every five years
after a general election instead we've
had two of them in just seven weeks you
can probably barely believe it neither
can I 1 pm out another one in but what
really changes Rishi sunak faces the
same economic problems the same party
divisions the same poor polling what he
hopes is that his new approach to the
economy to his party and his way of
doing politics will eventually help
shift the polls to
tomorrow his fast test at Prime
Minister's questions and there will be
plenty of them last month's leadership
loser now the winner but will he be able
to handle the prize Beth Rigby Sky News
in Westminster